Speaker 1: Donald Trump held multiple rallies
over this final weekend before the 2022 midterms.
We already looked at rallies, which Barack
Obama did.
Let's now look at Trump.
Donald Trump's rally was so disastrous, half
the crowd started leaving early.
Reporters reported that half of the crowd
was walking out as Donald Trump was still
speaking.
One of the new totally propagandistic things
that Trump has brought back is flying in on
his plane.
This is the plane his own followers funded
for him to get repainted and to get back in
the air.
And you would think at some point these people
would go.
You know, I donated all that money to Trump.
He didn't do a damn thing for me.
I still have no savings.
I'm still in this terrible situation here
in Latrobe, Pennsylvania.
But he's flying in on a brand new painted
plane.
Maybe I should stop.
Maybe it's time to stop.
Overt fascistic propaganda shows up with the
cheering cultists, but they don't think about
it.
They just go, Yeah, this is the guy I'm supposed
to be voting for, so let's get right into
it.
Inside the cult.
Donald Trump did something interesting.
He referred to Ron DeSantis as Ron the sanctimonious
showing us he was going public with the civil
war between him and DeSantis.
Speaker 2: Party for the nomination like nobody's
ever seen before.
Let's say there it is, Trump at 71 Ron to
sanctimonious that 10%.
Speaker 1: Now people didn't like this.
Later, when we look at the Florida rally that
Trump did, Trump didn't invite DeSantis, but
he did say vote for Rubio, vote for DeSantis.
In the not even 24 hours between the Pennsylvania
rally and the Florida rally, people went to
Trump and said that was not a good look.
Narcissists don't like sharing the spotlight.
Trump is furious that the Santos refuses to
say, I won't run against Trump in 24.
So he went with Ron to sanctimonious Republicans,
told him, Don't do that.
That's not a good idea.
And Trump backing off of it.
By the following rally, Donald Trump wrongly
claimed that the Pennsylvania Supreme Court
ruled.
That he won the 2020 election there.
Take a listen.
Speaker 2: That basically said we were all
right two weeks ago.
A week ago.
You're all just about all Democrats.
Supreme Court of Pennsylvania said they were
right.
The 2020 election, with respect to the ballots
and everything else, that 2020 election was
not right.
It was not right.
It was not allowed.
Speaker 1: That is not what the Pennsylvania
Supreme Court ruled.
Trump is lying overtly.
What the Pennsylvania Supreme Court ruled
about a week ago is that undated ballots in
the 2022 primary were invalid 2022 primary
undated ballots.
They did not rule that things were not right
in 2020, and certainly not that Donald Trump
won.
Donald Trump continuing to talk about 2020.
Speaker 2: And you're all Democrat, mostly,
I think just about all Democrats.
Supreme Court.
Speaker 1: I'm sorry.
This is this is part of the clip we just looked
at.
Okay.
Let's continue.
Donald Trump talking about his relationship
with the Chinese President Xi.
And Trump saying I call him the king now.
Speaker 2: I necessary.
When I went to China because I actually until
the China virus came in I had a great relationship
with President Xi is now president for life.
I call him king.
He says, no, no, no, I am not king.
I am president.
I said, you're president for life.
Therefore, you're the king as far as I'm concerned.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: There are times in American history
where for a president to say, I basically
am calling this authoritarian strongman the
king, that would be a humiliating blunder
for a for a president or former president
to say.
And the crowd cheers.
Now, this is how depraved and debased the
right wing has become.
Donald Trump then exploding in an unintelligible
word salad about the media being the enemy
of the people and Russia.
It's unintelligent.
It's diarrhea of the mouth.
Speaker 2: Folks, communism.
This is getting to be what they're doing with
Catherine Engelbrecht and everybody.
This is like a communist country and the people.
We're not standing for a communist country.
Speaker 1: Well, there is no such country
here in the U.S., so you don't have to stand
for it or sit.
We came too.
Speaker 2: Far because honestly, they have
nothing going.
Their policy is crazy.
The only thing they do well is misinformation
and cheat on elections.
That's the only thing.
And they're really good at that.
The radical Democrats are locking up pro-life.
And you know this.
You see this, the pro-life activists, they're
being locked up all over the place.
They're persecuting their political opponents.
I wonder who?
Nobody.
A friend of mine said.
A friend of mine said, there's never been
a president that's been treated like you.
After he gets you know, when you get out of
office, you go and these guys come at you
left and right on such bullshit.
You've never seen anything like it.
Speaker 1: Another thing is that the crowds
are so childish that when Trump swears, the
crowd cheers like that's cool.
I mean, it's it's quite literally like eight
year olds.
Speaker 2: Spying on their political rivals.
Remember, they spied on my campaign.
Speaker 1: And remember, they did not spy
on Trump's campaign.
Just as a reminder.
Just as a reminder, Trump's campaign in 2015
and 2016 was in touch with so many suspected
criminals and spies that because those suspected
criminals and spies were being surveilled.
Trump's people were coincidentally overheard
because they were in touch with those suspected
criminals and spies.
It's out of this world stuff.
And Trump just says, Oh, they spied on my
campaign.
They spied on my campaign.
Trump then talks about documents, the entire
document thing, and he tells lies there as
well.
Speaker 2: New Air Force One now.
Air Force One is actually two planes.
It's two 747 eight hundreds, by.
Speaker 1: The way, nothing more relatable
than when Trump talks about planes and private
planes.
Speaker 2: And they're quite, quite the plane.
I will tell you.
In fact, I can't even tell you what's on this
plane because it might be top secret and they'll
try and say, oh, he violated a document.
Speaker 1: He violated a document.
Listen, he everybody's accusing Trump of of
assault.
Now, even the documents.
Speaker 2: He's violated every other president
takes their documents.
I'm the only one.
I can't have a document but everyone else,
they got him all over the place.
They have them in Chinese restaurants and
bowling alleys.
You know that, right?
Speaker 1: Now, remember, that's also a lie.
What Trump is referring to is there was one
point at which the National Archives actually
legally and officially rented a building that
previously housed a restaurant in order to
temporarily store documents the archives had
them.
The idea that George H.W.
Bush stuffed some documents in a Chinese laundry,
like in the in the dryer.
It's completely absurd.
So then the crowd starts leaving, half the
crowd reportedly leaving while Trump was still
speaking.
They bring up Mehmet Oz.
Mehmet Oz says tomorrow before the Steeler
game.
Call ten people and make sure they vote.
The only problem the Steelers didn't have
a game yesterday, but Oz, who isn't even really
from Pennsylvania, has no clue what's going
on.
Speaker 2: Tomorrow morning, when you awaken,
I want you to contact ten people.
Do it at church, two before the Steelers game.
Just find the time.
And here's the question you're going to ask
them.
Are you happy with the way America is going?
Speaker 1: Right.
There was no Steelers game yesterday, Sunday.
OSNOS So little about Pennsylvania that he
doesn't even know when the Steelers play.
And of course, actual Steelers fans, I assure,
you know, when the Steelers play.
The rally was also in support of Doug Mastriano.
Doug Mastriano took a different approach,
which was during his brief moment in the in
the limelight during the rally.
He just groveled before Trump, which is really
what Trump likes.
Speaker 5: It in Pennsylvania, Mr. President.
Pennsylvania loves you.
We need you.
He was such a great president that even Vladimir
Putin behaved for four years.
Vladimir, it's amazing.
Absolutely fantastic.
Pennsylvania, three days away from victory.
We're going to take back our state recently.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: So Mastriano was on message.
He was just praising Trump.
That's what you're supposed to do.
And then lastly, and this was really weird,
Trump brought up Christian televangelist lunatic
Kenneth Copeland, and it got really weird.
Speaker 2: There are things in.
Speaker 5: This great state of Pennsylvania.
Liberty was born here.
I've been accused of being a Christian nationalist.
Speaker 2: Our first president.
Yeah.
1789.
Speaker 1: This is not slowed down, by the
way.
Speaker 2: Bible it's 17th chapter of Genesis
where God.
Speaker 5: Made a covenant with Abraham and
he read that and he.
Speaker 2: Bowed his knee.
Speaker 5: Oh, God.
And he prayed.
Speaker 1: Anyway, I won't play the full 2
minutes.
Trump was completely bored during this and
very clearly regretted bringing up Kenneth
Copeland absolutely deranged rally.
We were there.
Our correspondent Luke Beasley was on the
ground in Latrobe.
We'll have those clips after the break.
Remember, if you watch our content, make sure
you're subscribe to the podcast on whatever
podcast platform you use, it's free and make
sure you are subscribed on YouTube.
I just got updated numbers from October 3.2
million individual people watched.
Our clips aren't subscribed on YouTube.
If just those 3.2 million people subscribe,
we would immediately be tied for the biggest
progressive YouTube channel
on
the Internet.